type 2 diabetes is a condition in which
your blood sugar level is too high
carbohydrates are substances your body
uses to make energy after you eat food
that contains carbohydrates
it eventually goes to your small
intestine
in your small intestine the food is
broken down into single sugar molecules
called glucose the cells in your small
intestine soak up the sugars
which pass into your bloodstream
when the blood reaches your pancreas it
detects the high amount of sugar in your
blood normally this causes your pancreas
to put a chemical called insulin into
your bloodstream
the insulin reduces the amount of sugar
in your blood to a healthy level
how does insulin do this
as the blood moves through your body
the insulin and sugar exit the
bloodstream into your tissues to reach
your cells
most cells have structures on their
surfaces called insulin receptors when
insulin flows by it attaches to the
receptors
the insulin acts like a key in a lock to
open up the cell
so the sugar can get inside
now your cell can use the sugar to make
the energy it needs to work properly
and your blood sugar level drops back to
its normal range
if you have type 2 diabetes your cells
don't respond to insulin as they should
this is called insulin resistance
when this happens your insulin cannot
unlock the cells to let sugar in because
the lox or insulin receptors are missing
or aren't working
as a result sugar is locked out of your
cells
when sugar can't get into your cells it
builds up in your bloodstream
this is a condition called hyperglycemia
in response to the high blood sugar
levels your pancreas makes more and more
insulin the overworked cells in your
pancreas try to keep up
but they slowly lose their ability to
make enough insulin these problems may
lead to the symptoms of type 2 diabetes
if you have questions about type 2
diabetes or any medications you have
been prescribed speak with your doctor
it is important to take your medications
as directed by your doctor tell him or
her about any side effects you have
this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or enmol
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
you